we have the latest breaking news report
on former president bill clinton he's
now been hospitalized fox news medical
contributor marty mccary is with us
marty uh we wish the president well we
always we obviously have political
differences but unlike liberals uh i
actually care about human life i hope
he's going to be okay what are your
thoughts on what you hear
i do too sean he has admitted to the
university of california irvine medical
center with what's described to be a
blood infection
and specifically a condition known as
sepsis and there's a wide variety of
variation in what sepsis is it could be
a mild infection or it can be
life-threatening we are told that it is
not covid
and um that he is on the men so we do
wish him well and it does look like he's
doing a little better on antibiotics for
this infection
okay let's because i i have heard and
you're right there are varying degrees
of it but the worst side of it can be
very dangerous can it not
yeah that's right as a matter of fact
many people who die in an icu die of
sepsis is when an infection goes out of
control in one system and overwhelmed
the physiology of one system he is 75
years of age so
his immune defenses are going to be a
little weaker he has had a heart bypass
procedure in the past called a cabbage
so perhaps the physiology is a little
weakened but it's reassuring to know
he's doing better
yeah uh okay we appreciate it you know
i've said this too about we're gonna get
to the joe rogan story in a little bit
here you know
the idea why isn't everybody happy that
whatever protocol he used in conjunction
with his own doctor that he's okay and
healthy how many times have i said i
want every american in afghanistan home
i don't care what the politics are uh if
they're coming home to get me fired full
time and work to get me fired full time
i still want them home if every liberal
that gets coveted wants to get well to
get me fired because they don't like my
opinions i still want them to get well
you don't often you don't always see
that from the left you can look at
comments at different times and and it's
it's pretty brutal out there especially
people that are anonymous in their
basement in their underwear anyway dr
mccary thank you we'll follow this story
throughout the night hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else